and a man found murdered in a room at a
Las Vegas strip Resort tonight the two
women accused of killing him facing the
judge now for the first time eight news
now reporter Victoria Saha joining us
live from Caesars where this happened
with who the victim is and the women
Behind Bars
yeah Brian and Denise still so many
questions today as to
had invited the two women up to his room
right before being shot
twenty-year-old Erica Covington and
Ariana Taylor both making their first
appearance in court Wednesday both with
a somber look much different from the
mug shots that were taken of them just
hours after their arrest police say 25
year old Ryan altamarano Serrano was
found shot in a hotel room by
housekeeping about 11 30 Monday morning
police tell us so far their
investigation is leading them to believe
Alta Murano Serrano wed to his hotel
room with Covington and Taylor the two
women later left his room with some of
his personal belongings they were
arrested by the criminal apprehension
team and booked into the Clark County
Detention Center early Wednesday
foreign
do remain in jail tonight without bail
and they will be back in court on Monday
both of their family members were
actually present in the courtroom but
they declined an interview reporting
live near Caesars tonight Victoria sahab
eight news now Victoria thank you
Covington and Taylor facing several
charges including open murder conspiracy
to commit murder as well as robbery